und jetzt das heute journal
mit hanna zimmermann und christian
sievers
hallo und guten abend eine handvoll
weiße tulpen reicht für einen
polizeieinsatz
bilder aus einem moskauer park von
oppositionellen aktivisten heute
verbreitet sechs polizisten führen eine
frau empire blumenstrauß wird gewertet
als illegale kundgebung
so weit ist es gekommen
die ukraine rechnet unterdessen mit
heftigen angriffen im osten offenbar hat
sich die russische armee dort neu
gruppiert und aufgestellt die gesamte
region kiew habe die ukraine wieder
unter kontrolle
aber präsident selensky sagt im osten
unseres landes bleibt die lage sehr
schwierig oliver reichert berichtet
sie haben es geschafft flüchtlinge aus
mario pohl sie sind den support er
angekommen vorerst in sicherheit
auch wenn es eine lange schwere fahrt
war durch russisch besetztes gebiet
wir haben uns lange aufgehalten nach
gründen gesucht den conversion stopp und
nicht durch zu lassen sie haben bis zum
letzten moment gewartet bis es dunkel
war und dann haben sie uns den korridor
freigegeben
das sind mehr als 3000 menschen die
durch diesen korridor dem krieg vorerst
entronnen sind
der krieg verteilt sich neu in der
ukraine im norden werden in den
vergangenen 24 stunden keine neuen
angriffe gemeldet auch in der stadt
hennef nicht wieder gewinne selbst
berichtet
dank gott und den ukrainischen
streitkräften war die nacht in cerny
erfand in der region ruhig
es gab keine bombenangriffe
aber auch da wo die ukrainische armee
wieder ein rückt offenbaren sich bilder
des grauens leichen in bucha einem
vorort von kiew erschossen und liegen
gelassen
diese menschen sind einfach nur hier
entlang gegangen und sind ohne grund
erschossen worden
in der nächsten nachbarschaft war es
noch schlimmer sie haben geschossen ohne
fragen zu stellen
bombenangriffe werden aus dem osten
gemeldet zur harke und aus den
separatisten gebieten donets und lohans
aber auch aus städten im süden und
vereinzelt aus dem zentrum die kämpfe
verlagern sich in den süden und in den
osten
im osten bleibt die situation extrem
kompliziert ich die russische truppen
rücken in den don was vor und richtung
kharkiv sie bereiten neue angriffe vor
wir bereiten eine effektivere
verteidigung vor
im südukrainischen nikolaev bergen
rettungskräfte heute 33 leichen opfer
eines russischen eingriffs anfang der
woche solche funde mehren sich in den
verschiedensten orten der ukraine
bringen wir unseren komponenten in der
ukraine mit dazu hier brase seit
längerem dort wird das land morgen
verlassen jörg oder narben zeit
vielleicht für eine zwischenbilanz die
usa also ist die meldung heute geben
jetzt noch mal 300 millionen dollar
rüstungs hilfe wenn du durchs land fährt
wenn du siehst wie es dort zugeht hast
du den eindruck die ukraine ist
gewappnet für einen sehr langen krieg
also darauf stimmt präsident selensky
jedenfalls sein volk ein er sagt dieser
konflikt wird noch lange dauern denn er
will natürlich auch dem gegner den
eindruck vermitteln dass die ukraine
darauf vorbereitet ist aber wir haben
wirklich sehr sehr viele leute gesehen
männer frauen egal welchen alters die
sich freiwillig melden für die
bürgerwehr die sich ausbilden lassen im
gebrauch von waffen obwohl viele solche
sachen noch nie in der hand gehabt haben
vorher es gibt private initiativen die
essen kochen für die soldaten an der
front die dann organisieren dass dieses
es noch in die kampfgebiete gefahren
wird also der widerstands wille der
bevölkerung er ist wirklich sehr sehr
beeindruckend hier die ukraine ist fast
doppelt so groß wie deutschland wie
unterschiedlich zeigt sich denn der
krieg in diesem land
das land ist de facto zweigeteilt wir
haben im prinzip die provinzen im osten
entlang der russischen grenze wo
wirklich krieg herrscht in dem sinne
dass ich da armeen gegenüber stehen dass
der soldaten aufeinandertreffen dass der
tod und leid herrscht und im anderen in
der anderen hälfte des landes also
westlich von kiew da bekommt man
manchmal den eindruck dass gar kein
krieg herrscht in der ukraine hier in
lemberg zum beispiel das sind die läden
offen die restaurants sind offen das
straßenleben sieht ganz normal aus jetzt
ist das hier natürlich durchgangsstation
für flüchtlinge es ist nachschub station
insofern bekommt man es dann schon mit
aber de facto ist die ukraine
zweigeteilt und wenn man das sieht dann
kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen dass
russland zuvor hatte die ukraine oder
vielleicht hätte man es auch militärisch
würde man es gar nicht können die
ukraine wirklich komplett zu erobern und
zu beherrschen und deshalb ist das was
wir den vergangenen tagen sehen dass was
was ich auch hier beobachte dass man
sich im moment jedenfalls tatsächlich
auf die sogenannte befreiung des donners
also die gebiete im osten des landes
konzentriert live aus der ukraine jörg
brase herzlichen dank
hunderttausende geflüchtete aus der
ukraine sind bereits bei uns in
deutschland das ziel ist diesen menschen
eine perspektive zu bieten also
jobcenter stadt sozialamt oder besser
noch jobstart jobcenter und es gibt über
vermittlungsplattformen online bereits
tausende stellenangebote
es gibt allerdings auch die berüchtigte
deutsche regulierungswut aus der praxis
berichtet peter böhme
neue ort neue arbeit neues leben für
nicola mirontschik und seine familie er
ist metallbauer aus kiew kam per zug
landete in münchen und arbeitet nun für
einen fensterbau betrieb im emsland am
montag gehts richtig los nicola sagt es
ist ein gottesgeschenk
ist es friedlich niemand wirft bomben
oder schießt raketen ich denke ich werde
hier fuß fassen wenn ich nach dem krieg
hier niemand rauswirft möchte ich hier
bleiben ich fühle mich hier wie ein
fisch im wasser am richtigen ort
so sieht es auch sein firmenchef sie
haben nicola den job feuer schmackhaft
gemacht videos vom betrieb geschickt und
fotos von der firmen wohnung die makula
mit familie nun bewohnen kann
wir haben 50 vollbeschäftigung wie
üblich wurde prozent arbeitslosigkeit
heißt also vom bezieht vollbeschäftigung
und wir sind
sondern leute wie nicolai zu bekommen
das ist so schnell klappte liegt an der
online-plattform jockey ukraine der
coesfelder unternehmer marcus diekmann
hat sie ehrenamtlich aufgebaut mit
sponsorengeldern sein ob er aus kiew
pollina und er hatten die idee 16.000
angebote bisher 1500
vorstellungsgespräche 200 vermittlungen
jobs aus allen bereichen it fachleute
ärzte krankenschwestern in münchen paris
oder auch in köstendorf in brandenburg
und eine befürchtung meine größte sorge
ist dass die menschen aus der aus der
angst aus der sorge heraus schnell einen
job kriegen zu müssen einfach jeden job
annehmen und nicht den job den
qualifikationen entsprechen und das wäre
schade für uns weil wir haben fachkräfte
man das ja auch schade für die menschen
habe das potenzial nicht auslassen da
dürfte er nicht unrecht haben und das
liegt am deutschen arbeitsrecht bisher
kommen vor allem ukrainerinnen mit
kindern nach deutschland
ukrainische frauen sind gut ausgebildet
viele akademikerinnen viele mit
medizinischen und technischen berufen
genau das was hierzulande außer handwerk
und landwirtschaft auch gesucht wird das
problem solche berufe gehören in die
ellenlange liste geschützter berufe die
erst mal anerkannt werden müssen
in dem moment wo die berufliche
qualifikation nur teilweise anerkannt
wird wo die bildungsabschlüsse nachholen
müssen wo sie bestimmte
ausbildungsmodule nachholen müssen dann
kann es sehr schnell sehr viel länger
dauern dann sind wir schnell bei
zeiträumen von über einem jahr im
bereich der hofstaat verwenden und wenn
dann können das auch mehrere jahre weil
der bund hat zwar die wichtigkeit
zügiger prüfer fahren betont aber ob das
in der praxis auch klappt könnte also
sein dass viele menschen erstmal in
prekären jobs landen die gewerkschaften
sind alarmiert das ist wichtig dass die
schutzregelungen die wir haben in
deutschland zum beispiel der gesetzliche
mindestlohn auch arbeitszeit regelungen
eingehalten werden überwacht werden
durch betriebs und personalräte aber
natürlich auch durch die entsprechenden
aufsichtsbehörden in den ländern nicola
mirontschik bekommt zwölf euro die
stunde wenn er sich bewährt wird er
verdienen wie seine kollegen er sagt er
habe als man legal ausweisen dürfen weil
eines seiner kinder eine behinderung hat
eine ausnahmeregel er sieht seine
zukunft in deutschland
und hanna hat die übersicht jetzt über
weitere wichtige nachrichten an diesem
samstag in dieser nacht ist schluss mit
den meisten corona beschränkungen in
deutschland entfällt zum beispiel die
masken pflicht an vielen orten wie im
supermarkt oder im restaurant und es
weit muss der mund nasenschutz nur noch
in der bahn und im flugzeug getragen
werden aber auch kliniken oder
pflegeheime können dies anordnen die
große ausnahme sind hamburg und
mecklenburg vorpommern
hier gilt die hotspot regelung das heißt
die bisherigen beschränkungen bestehen
weiter
sri lankas präsident rajapakse hat nach
heftigen ausschreitungen die
militärpräsenz im land deutlich
ausgebaut außerdem wurde eine
ausgangssperre verhängt weil für morgen
weitere proteste geplant sind zuvor
hatte rajapakse landesweit den notstand
ausgerufen
am donnerstag hatten hunderte
demonstranten gewaltsam versucht das
haus des präsidenten zu stürmen und
seinen rücktritt gefordert
grund für die proteste ist eine schwere
wirtschaftskrise in sri lanka mit massiv
steigenden
lebensmittelpreisen treibstoffmangel und
täglich stundenlangen stromausfällen
für musliminnen und muslime hat heute
der fastenmonat ramadan begonnen
im saudiarabischen mekka umrundeten
tausende pilgern die kaaba das
wichtigste heiligtum des islam die
gläubigen verzichten nun einen monat
lang von sonnenaufgang bis untergang auf
essen trinken und andere genüsse
weltweit gibt es etwa 1,9 milliarden
muslime
die preise für strom und gas gedeckelt
ein tank rabatt von 18 cent auf jeden
liter plus eine steuerfreie kaufkraft
prämie von bis zu 6000 euro die ab
sommer kommen soll was klingt wie aus
der deutschen diskussion um maßnahmen
gegen explodierende preise ist bereits
konkrete politik in frankreich es ist
gleichzeitig der versuch von
staatspräsidentin manuell makro die
stimmung in den griff zu bekommen kurz
vor einer wahl bei der er nicht sicher
sein kann ob er sie gewinnt noch nie
zuvor war laut einer umfrage die
bereitschaft der französinnen und
franzosen so groß radikal zu wählen also
extrem rechts oder extrem links thomas
walde es ist nur noch eine woche bis zum
ersten wahlgang und die anhänger des
amtierenden präsidenten versammeln sich
zum ersten mal ist der alte kann jetzt
zeit für den üblichen wahlkampf er
kümmerte sich um europa und um diesen
krieg
viele franzosen wersen auf seine präsenz
in den medien und auf veranstaltungen
und mit dem heutigen tag wird der
aufschwung von marine le pen in den
umfragen beendet
der präsident betritt die arena die
wucht des auftritts die inszenierung
sollen zeigen emanuel machen ist da in
den vergangenen wochen konzentrierte er
sich fernab der öffentlichkeit auf den
krieg in der ukraine heute ganz auf die
innen und sozialpolitik makro
verteidigte seine bilanz die
arbeitslosigkeit sei niedrig er kündigte
programme für mehr soziale gerechtigkeit
und bessere aufstiegschancen an
dollar durch arbeit durch produktion
können wir in den kommenden fünf jahren
unser wachstum steigern mehr wohlstand
schaffen und den fortschritt fortsetzen
[Musik]
marien präsidentin laut umfragen ist die
nationalisten marine le pen inzwischen
macros hauptkonkurrentin dass sie in der
vergangenheit wladimir putin verteidigte
will sie vergessen machen sie hofft auf
die stimmen der unzufriedenen verspricht
zuwanderung zu begrenzen und die
kaufkraft der arbeitenden menschen zu
erhöhen
ich kämpfe dafür dass jeder franzose
mindestens 150 bis 200 euro im monat
mehr bekommt weil ich weiß dass sie mit
den hohen preisen nicht mehr klarkommen
das spiel des anderen rechtsaußen ihrem
uhr geht unterdessen nicht auf nach
anfänglich guten umfragewerten geht ihm
die puste aus er verspricht ein
abschiebe ministerium heute wurde er
rausgeworfen aus einer fußballhalle sie
hätten uns informieren müssen was sie
hier vorhaben wir dürfen also nicht hier
sein obwohl wir dem platz reserviert
haben nun gut
unter zahlreichen linken kandidatin gilt
als der aussichtsreichste mehr
mindestlohn weniger arbeitszeit höhere
steuern für gutverdiener und rente schon
ab 60
weil radikale veränderung
die franzosen müssen absolut souverän
sein wir verteidigen uns ganz allein
darum haben wir nach meiner meinung
nichts in der nato zu suchen die
kandidatin der einstmals bedeutenden
sozialistischen und konservativen
parteien gelten als chancenlos so
zeichnet sich in frankreich eine wahl ab
zwischen einem weiter so und radikaler
veränderung
und jetzt die lottozahlen von diesem
samstag die lauten 14 37 38 40 46 49
superzahl 2 alle angaben wie immer ohne
gewähr
geht noch der blick aufs wetter das sich
in den nächsten tagen wechselhaft zeigt
morgen teils aufgelockert teils stark
bewölkt im norden regen und schnee
regenschauer am alpenrand letzte
schneeschauer vor allem in der mitte
auch länger sonne ich ein bis acht grad
am montag im norden sehr nass und
stürmisch im süden freundlicher bei 4
bis 10 grad danach sehr wechselhaft bei
teils stürmischen wind und wieder melda
wieder milder das führe ich sehr gerne
für heute danke dass sie bei uns waren
und gegen 0.25 gibt's dann hier die
heute express mit christopher wehrmann
bis morgen angenehm haben
[Musik]